foreign
[Music]
the full trail of Godzilla minus one has
now been released and ever since the
first minute we have been analyzing the
footage piece by piece and there are a
lot of things we have to tell you so
strap yourself up for a hell of a g-ride
let's get to it it starts out with a
scene of a lot of people running around
scared and panicking a person asks what
is it and gets a reply I don't know
something big this piece right here
would be in Japan around a couple of
years after the end of World War II and
it seems ripe with Mars shock and panic
imagine yourself in a crowded place and
someone shouts bomb or you hear a
shooting then everyone starts running
towards you and away from you what do
you do normally a person would follow
the hurt mentality and flee in the same
direction as everyone else so this scene
here is very appropriate when a giant
monster is approaching and the only
thing you hear is boom boom boom a Roar
and someone saying it's something big
the first part ends with a couple of
train drivers screaming and a carriage
being thrown into the tracks by God
Zella obviously the same scene we saw in
the first teaser
so yeah the credits show that the
movie's VFX writing and directing is
being done by Takashi yamazaki we're not
really all by himself but he is in
charge of managing these three things
then we see an awesome sight one of
Godzilla slowly emerging from behind a
dust cloud this is so freaking awesome
I'm sorry you gotta be professional here
there were some debris falling from the
size as you can see and therefore it is
Godzilla rubbing his shoulder against
one of the tall buildings in Tokyo as
you would see later Godzilla wouldn't be
as big as the most of us are Shin's
version he would be as we had predicted
around 60 meters 200 feet tall I mean he
is taller than most boost World
buildings there in Japan but at that
time but not by much the next couple of
scenes we see were the same ones from
the teaser but here it drags on for a
few more seconds showing us a lot more
details like Godzilla actually biting
the train in the metro line with his
powerful bite force even metal bends
like piece of confetti paper then we see
the part where he swipes his tail
destroying buildings and wiping away
human Souls with utter disregard for
everything this movie was stated to be a
horror flick and yeah being in such
terrifying situations try to save your
life only to be smacked by a tail that's
bigger than a house is something that
you would take with you to the afterlife
and tell your maker about it the next
scene is when he Stomps on the ground
and sends hundreds of people flying in
the air that's something that most of us
should learn physics [__] no disrespect
when a 50 000 ton monster puts his foot
down concrete will break the ground will
shatter and people will believe they can
fly and believe they can touch the sky
yeah that's physics
as you can see Godzilla walks slowly
with a few seconds after each step but
his size is that big that people running
around at full speed cannot even out
distance the Big G this scene also shows
the feet are wider and bigger than that
of Godzilla 1998 for example who was
around the same size the first half of
the trailer ends with a huge explosion a
nuclear explosion and when you pause the
scene Godzilla is standing right next to
the explosion this tells us that the U.S
military will do whatever it takes to
kill Gojira at the expense of another
bomb being dropped on Japan some of you
might say oh it's Godzilla using the
atomic breath nope the shock wave in the
scene right after that would disprove
that theory and also his dorsal plates
didn't light up but don't worry you'll
see an atomic breath here in this
trailer you just need to know where to
look and pause
so okay the same teaser scenes Japan
from 0 to -1 blah blah blah we've
discussed this in a previous video but
to those who have never seen it or who
are new here and don't know what's going
on a month back Toho released the very
first tease of Godzilla minus one a new
movie that will be released in 3rd of
November and the 1st of December in the
United States and it's the same scenes
here of Japan after a nuke and now come
to think of it maybe this is after the
nuclear bomb that was used to try and
kill Godzilla yeah we have seen
Hiroshima and Nagasaki I mean the
aftermath pictures and this one looks
really different the architecture of the
buildings yeah maybe this is the scene
of them trying to kill Godzilla for the
very first time with an atomic bomb and
that's why in the last scenes of this
movie trailer we will get to see a
Gojira that is very different in
coloration and skin texture like a
Monster who has been burned by extreme
heat and radiation maybe this is why the
leaks of the two Godzillas came from
interesting to think about it might even
be true
so right after that we see Godzilla
swimming beneath a U.S frigate or a
destroyer but definitely it's not a
battleship as of the size and the design
and as we have discussed in the previous
video on the origins and the Encounters
of this Godzilla with the US Navy as per
the recent teaser the clips the human
ships are of no match to the king of the
monsters Godzilla will just lay a path
of Destruction wherever he goes to and
will sing quite a few battleships and
submarines this Godzilla is definitely
on a part of Vengeance and destruction
maybe these previous Encounters in the
oceans resulted in the U.S declaring
all-out war on the creature and having
seen that no conventional weapon can
hurt it resorts to the atomic bomb at
the cost of Tokyo and Japanese lives
maybe it's not Tokyo maybe it's a
different town and then you know
Godzilla comes back and destroys Tokyo
later on yamazaki is a nationalist after
all and this would be a way of him to
air out his frustration at the Hiroshima
and Nagasaki incidents against the US
even though it's ancient history by now
anyway after that we see dead people in
the beach and a task force being
assembled to study and find a way to end
the threat of Godzilla It also says that
the government is hiding the truth and
concealing the presence of the monster
from the public and it is their job a
certain group of people to bring this
out into the Limelight and yeah the
Japanese Einstein looking guy guess who
that is it's [__] ishiro serizawa bro
the Stars Force against Godzilla in the
Open Seas will lead to him finding out
the secrets to the G-Man and maybe his
ultimate development of the oxygen
Destroyer weapon to kill the king of the
monsters we see Godzilla about to rip
apart a new hole in the U.S Navy ship
and a destination of Godzilla is Tokyo
as we can see in the clips like bits and
pieces of it and then right then and
there if you pause or slow down the clip
you'd see the atomic breath destroying a
battleship from underneath the ocean in
the same way that the most diverse
Godzilla destroyed the aircraft carrier
in GVK but here the explosion becomes
something akin to that of a nuclear bomb
this is way more awesome in my opinion
we then see further scenes of
Destruction and people acting out their
frustration on each other since the
bigger problem Godzilla is beyond any
one of them to solve their ship
wreckages everywhere and the entire city
is in rubble and the best scene here is
when a ship gets thrown into the docks
like it was nothing and a statement by
one of the people there saying that the
monster will never forgive us implying
that maybe Godzilla has a deeper
connection to the Japanese prior to the
events of -1 or maybe he was seen by
some as a mythical sea god or a spirit
that is only spoken about in Whispers
and the second world war the events of
it the entire six years of second world
war and the atomic bombings brought him
out to destroy Humanity seeing that the
entire species who kills each other for
no apparent reason in the eyes of
Godzilla is doomed to be doomed let's
say but hey that's just a guess
so the last scenes of the trailer shows
two words survive and fight which
epitomizes the spirit of the Japanese
people during World War II when the even
in the most desperate battles they fight
on and even resorting to Kamikaze
attacks to bleed out the Allied Forces
who were overwhelming anyway we then see
Godzilla's feet in the beach and his
skin texture here seems to have changed
quite a bit appearing darker and burnt
the explosion in the earlier scenes
drive him back underwater only for him
to come back with a vengeance later on
seems to look like it but we can only
find out on November when the movie hits
the screens or maybe December but then
the very last scene tells us two things
he definitely survives a nuclear attack
and is now pissed off even more than he
ever was and his Roar is different being
more coarse and has a lower tone to it
even though it still holds the iconic
sound
[Music]
yeah something like that it feels more
hurt and angry as well but still I love
the sound
so that's all we have to say about the
trailer as for now we will come again
with other videos breaking it into
further details you know microscopic
details anyway I hope you have enjoyed
watching this video do hit that like
button for support and subscribe to push
us through in the YouTube algorithm but
most of all smash that Bell icon for
regular updates and new videos right
here on this channel till the next one
take care fam